♪ ♪
>> IT'S TOO BAD THAT THE WORLD
PUTS US IN A POSITION LIKE THAT
BUT NOW WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME
FURTHER DECISIONS.
SO THEY WILL BE MARRIED FAIRLY
SOON.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO ENGAGE IN
THE CIVIL WAR ITSELF.
IN THE WORST INTEREST OF NOT
JUST THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
CONVENTION BUT CIVILIZATION
ITSELF.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
DEFENSE SECRETARY MATTA SETTING
THE STAGE FOR WHAT LOOKS LIKE AN
EMINENT MILITARY STRIKE IN SYRIA
BUT EXACTLY WHEN AND HOW BIG,
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
STEPHEN HAYES, OF "THE WEEKLY
STANDARD."
SUSAN PAGE FROM "USA TODAY," AND
CHARLES HURT OF
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
THE PRESIDENT, SECRETARY
MEDICINE TOP NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS ALL MET AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY WE ARE TOLD
THAT SECONDARY MATTA HAS
PRESENTED THE PRESIDENT WITH
VARIOUS OPTIONS.
STEVE, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING
ABOUT THE TIMING AND SCOPE OF
WHATEVER THE U.S. RESPONSE IS
GOING TO BE?
>> NOBODY KNOWS.
IN PART BECAUSE EVEN IF JAMES
MATTIS LAYS OUT A BATTLE PLAN
AND GAVE THE PRESIDENT A SERIES
OF OPTIONS IN THE PRESIDENT
SETTLES ON ONE TODAY, IT'S
UNCLEAR THAT WILL BE THE OPTION
THE PRESIDENT SETTLES ON
TOMORROW.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE WE WERE
EIGHT DAYS AGO, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES HAD HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM MEETING
AT THE WHITE HOUSE THING I WANT
TO END U.S. INVOLVEMENT IN SYRIA
IN 48 HOURS.
EVERYBODY OUT IN 48 HOURS.
HIS TEAM PUSHED BACK AGAINST
THAT, GAVE THE PRESIDENT OTHER
OPTIONS, SUGGESTING WE WOULD SEE
CHAOS OF VESSEL WE TRIED.
A MATTER OF DAYS LATER, THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING PUBLICLY
ABOUT DEEPENING U.S. INVOLVEMENT
IN SYRIA IN A PRETTY SERIOUS WAY
IN SYRIA IN A PRETTY SERIOUS WA
WAY.
TWEETING THREATS TO RUSSIA.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THERE IS NO
SERIOUS STRATEGY.
THERE IS NO SERIOUS STRATEGY.
TO THE QUESTIONS YOU POSED, WHEN
AND HOW BIG, I WOULD ADD TO WHAT
END?
WHAT'S THE OBJECTIVE?
>> Chris: ALONG THE LINES OF
AN UNCERTAIN PATH, YESTERDAY THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED AND REPORTED
ON IT LAST NIGHT, RUSSIA, GET
READY.
THE MISSILES WILL BE COMING.
TODAY HE PUT OUT THIS TWEET.
"NEVER SAID WHEN AN ATTACK ON
SYRIA WOULD TAKE PLACE.
COULD BE VERY SOON OR NOT
SO SOON AT ALL!"
THAT LED TO THIS EXCHANGE
BETWEEN THE DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYS MAYBE I
WILL, MAYBE I WON'T.
I WILL LET YOU KNOW IN 24 HOURS.
>> HE IS BEING DELIBERATE.
HE'S GOING THROUGH ALL THE
OPTIONS AND CONSULTING OUR
ALLIES.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT PRESIDENTS
OR DOING MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
>> Chris: SUSAN, I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT THE RUN-UP HAS
BEEN BUMPY BUT ISN'T THE
PRESIDENT TOO FAR DOWN THIS ROAD
NOW TO CALL OF A MILITARY STRIKE
WHENEVER IT HAPPENS?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
HE CLEARLY HAS SAID WE WILL
RESPOND MILITARILY TO THE
TERRIBLE PICTURES OF THE USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS THAT IT WILL BE
A BIGGER WALK BACK THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN HE DECIDED
NOT TO GO AHEAD AFTER SYRIA
CROSSED HIS REDLINE WITH ACTION.
THAT WAS SOMETHING TRUMP WAS
VERY CRITICAL OF AT THE TIME AND
HAS BEEN CRITICAL SINCE.
I THINK HE WILL REACT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES HE DO
AFTER THE MILITARY STRIKES TAKE
PLACE?
DOES IT SIGNAL A LONGER-TERM
COMMITMENT UNLIKE WHAT HE SAID
LAST WEEK?
DOES IT GET US ENGAGED IN A REAL
MILITARY COMPETITION WITH RUSSIA
WHICH WOULD HAVE ALL KINDS OF
PERILS.
>> Chris: THEN THERE WAS
DEFENSE SECRETARY MATTA'S
TELLING A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE TODAY THAT HE INTENDS
TO SEE INTERNATIONAL CHEMICAL
WEAPONS INSPECTORS ARRIVE IN
SYRIA WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN THIS WEEKEND.
THAT RAISES THE QUESTION OF
DELAY BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO
KNOW.
THIS HAPPENED SEVERAL DAYS AGO
ALREADY.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT
24 HOURS, 48 HOURS.
WE ARE WELL PAST THAT DEADLINE
ALREADY.
DELAY, CONSIDERATION, WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
DELIBERATION IS GOING ON, YOU
HAVE TO NOTE THAT THE RUSSIANS
AND IRANIANS AND SYRIANS ARE
BUSY HIDING ANY ASSETS THEY CAN
HIDE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
RAISES THE QUESTION ABOUT HOW
DEEPLY INVOLVED ARE WE GOING TO
GET, HOW INVOLVED ARE WE GOING
TO GET IN TERMS OF HAVING BOOTS
ON THE GROUND FOR EXAMPLE.
IF IT ACTUALLY COMES TO THAT.
PUTS US IN A TOUGH SITUATION.
WE HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS PATH
BEFORE.
WE KNOW TRUMP HAS SET MISSILES
INTO SYRIA FOR THIS VERY
INFRACTION BEFORE.
BUT IT'S NOT WHAT HE GOT ELECTED
FOR.
WHAT HE GOT ELECTED, HE GOT
ELECTED ON A LOT OF PROMISES TO
DISENGAGE FROM THINGS LIKE THIS.
I THINK IT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR
HIM IN TERMS OF THE PEOPLE THAT